[Music]  it is the ultimate eternal tribute to  your first love your mom the I love mom  heart tattoo iconic and below  the history of the imam centric tribute  dates back to the 1700s when sailors  were at the forefront of tattoo culture  picture this you're staring down a long  stint at sea possibly to never return  home these said sailors often wanted to  keep their loved ones close and what  could be any closer than a heart on your  arm  this heart could symbolize the heart of  a girlfriend a wife or mom it is even  said that mom can symbolize a love of  country the motherland if you will but  nothing says I love mom like this guy  Norman Collins aka sailor Jerry sailor  Jerry is the man who popularized in  polarised I love mom tattoo amongst many  others nowadays I love mom tattoos are  as popular as ever amongst those in the  service and civilians though the imagery  has changed a bit the heartfelt  sentiment remains the same we love you  mom  [Music]